في رمضان متحدث اقليمي باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه سامويل
اهلا بك معنا رمضان كريم ونقول صحه فطورك
اهلا وسهلا شكرا للاستضافه رنا رمضان كريم
ولكل مشاهدين انا فعلا مبسوط جدا ليكون
معكم وليكون هناك في دبي في الشرق الاوسط
في رمضان فعلا
اسره رمضانيه تحديدا لك شخصيا في رمضان في
منطقتنا العربيه وانت موجود معنا انا عايش
في بعض البلدان في هذا الوقت في هذا الشهر
الفضيل وفعلا كل البلد في هذه المنطقه
لديها تقاليد خس بها وانا احب ان استمتع
بتقاليد المهنيه مثلا هنا في دبي لدينا
المجلس لدينا صخور في الكويت انا اعيش في
الكويت سنتين ولديها في الكويت
الديوان الديوانيه وفي المغرب لازم الناس
يزور في رمضان ويستمتع بالحريره والشباكيه
بعد الهلويات اذا كل بلد لديها الطقوس
والتقاليد الخاص بالرمضان وفعلا انا دائما
اشجع اصدقائي وعائلاتي لزياره هذه المنطقه
في رمضان لان لازم الناس يشوفوا هذه
التقاليد فعلا
يعني اسمح لي اليوم احنا عم نقول انه
رمضان بعيون امريكيه واحنا بنقول لك كمان
انه اليوم سمول بعيون مساء العربيه نظره
مختلفه اليوم عم نشوف سامو كيف بعيش حياته
في رمضان يعني غير سام والذي نسمع تصريحات
الرسميه السياسيه طب سمول شو بتقدر
تحكيلنا كمان عن كرم العرب خصوصا مثلا في
الولائم والموائد الرمضانيه الكرامه العرب
بجوز لا يتجزا من الثقافه في هذه البلدان
من الثقافه في رمضان
اكثر من مره اكثر من من كميته لالف مرات
انا كنت استمتع
بالمائده الرمضانيه مع المصريين مع
الكويتيين ما المغاربه هنا في دبي
الاماراتيين مسعوديين اذا من الازمه الناس
يعرفوا ان اذا تريد انت عارف الكلام
الاستضافه في هذه المنطقه لازم تعرف ذلك
خلال شهر رمضان بدون شهر
فضول ما هي ابرز لما نتحدث عن رمضان تحدث
عن اطباق الرمضانيه ما هي ابرز اطباق
رمضانيه للتعرف عليها
ويفضلها اذا كمان معروف انا احب المغرب
انا عايش في المغرب بعد السنوات
في المغرب عندما تشوف الحريره والشباكيه
والابيض والتمر خلاص طاجين بعدين تاجين
لا كسكس هذا فقير جدا لازم كلها ممكن
في المائده الافطار في رمضان في المغرب
لازم تكون حريره والشباكيه شباكيه نوع من
الحلوى المغربيه وتمر والابيض خلاص ولكن
في بعض البلدان ممكن تشوف الشوربه اخرى
شوربه العدس وهذا اذا كل
الاكلات فعلا فريد في النوع في كل البلدان
في هذه المنطقه طيب سامي اليوم
عيد الفطر على الابواب ماذا تقول سامر لهم
انا اقول المنطقه باكمالها رمضان كريم
رمضان مبارك انا شخصيا هذا ليس
البيان الرسمي ولكن شخصيا انا فعلا اشعر
بالراحه عندما انا اعيش في هذه المنطقه
وانا اقضي وقتي في هذه المنطقه فعلا
واحنا اكيد بنشكرك جزيل الشكر المتحدث
الاقليمي باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
مساء العربيه هالمره شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات